hello i'm nicholas hoult this is lily
collins against way palms
what does Lily Collins tattoo say which
one I'll go with one of them the nature
of this flower is to bloom whoa and
that's all my foot very good very good
yeah I like that
what was the knee Colin's first movie
the voice right no technically the first
film is The Blind Side but I did like
clapping and singing in Tarzan
that's it toss I don't know if that
really counts children singing Tarzan
you're in it
how old is Lily Collins right now dirty
thirty get it how to get Lily Collins
eyebrows naturally just don't pluck away
that wouldn't work for me you've got
green eyebrows if I doesn't go any
wilder than I wouldn't wish is Lily
Collins vegetarian no I eat fish and
occasionally chicken so they know so I'm
not a vegetarian who is Lily Collins
related to oh the Collins plan tab woman
clan I mean my mom my dad my sister's my
brothers yeah just family like most
people related to family very good is
Nicholas Hoult in Game of Thrones yes I
am I'm very good in it great acting some
of my best work in Deadpool yes
so in Deadpool no no I'm not actually at
that book but I do get to do a cameo in
Deadpool 2 which was very happy about
because I was a fan of the first of all
are you in Game of Thrones no oh I was
like you said yes and I thought I bought
it no no not in Game of Thrones
auditioned didn't get it
been there done that
oh well isn't it assault related to Tom
Cruise yes
again brothers no another mother no
father yeah not related to Tom Cruise
did get to meet him once though which
was a lot of fun
what is Nicholas Hoult in Harry Potter
yes I was over in Harry Potter
again another brilliant performance you
probably don't recognize me but I was
very good in it
he was the invisibility cloak exactly
well lots of noise on that one I mean
lots of things careers going great is
Lily Collins British or American I'm
both I was born in England but live in
Los Angeles so technically I'm a dual
citizen although I do consider myself
more British than American best advice
is Lily Collins I thought there's gonna
be more to that perfect no definitely
not perfect I wrote a book a couple
years ago called unfiltered which
chapters exactly why I am not perfect
and why nobody is perfect sorry
is Lily Collins related to Audrey
Hepburn ah I would like to be but I'm
not
she's one of my idols and muses but no
we are not related do you want to play
her at some point I would be honored to
play Audrey Hepburn at some point good
I'm trying to read upside down a little
bit so it's tricky there's Lily Collins
hair naturally curly one of my searches
no it's not naturally curly I would say
maybe more on like the wavy side when
left to dry naturally forever wind blow
dried strength straight something's a
fake fake comes these are real curls
just I didn't wake honest okay is Lily
Collins Phil Collins daughter oh that
one is true true that is fact
I don't know about playing him in a
movie is Lily Collins in
scandalous scandalous I am in
relationship with myself no I'm having
fun I'm 30 now I'm living my life okay
sorry I wasn't I didn't want to get all
personal it was the thank you for
answering where Nicholas Hoult from from
Wokingham
in Berkshire England where I'm hoping to
be mayor of there Oh someday soon I've
got some big plans and they do you have
a big roller disco if I do so vote for
me you're gonna go round waking people
up right with a big Bell that's why I
thought mayor's did I kind of split time
between LA and London and wherever I'm
filming so all over the place in the
x-men movie that you are indeed in I am
actually in the expert I play Hank McCoy
also known as the Beast
what go to I went to the coos infant
school then odd the field junior school
in silver young stay at school for a
little bit and then Ranelagh secondary
school that's all of the schools in case
because I don't wasn't specific Nicholas
Hoult knitting
mad knitting Mad Max those a hobby I had
on the south I didn't knit Mad Max
incredible if you watch the movie and
you realize that it was just all
something but I knitted because but now
I knitted on the set of the film to pass
time so you knitted during Mad Max you
wrote poetry during the JD Salinger film
you don't poetry just like there is and
you've painted during prep for talking
huh
pick up some hobbies you get one of
these I knitted hats and scarves this
hats and scarves I mean I love to make
little bubbles - bubbles bubbles I quit
though I quit knitting because I got
orders to make hats for people on set
and I had to make two in one day and it
took me ten hours straight to make them
that's it
well it was one of my days off I didn't
open the curtains oh it was I went cold
turkey after that because it took the
joy of knitting Lily Collins where was
Lily Collins raised born in Guildford in
West Sussex in England and then moved to
Los Angeles when I was six so most of my
time was in LA but then I would go back
and forth to England did you have a
British accent at six I did had a very
very strong British accent but everyone
made fun of me at that age just wanted
to fit in so I used to watch Peter Pan
over and over again and just say Peter
Pan Peter Pan I don't may appear that
yeah huh no good friend does Lily
Collins sing I like to I use 15 musical
theatre and I have sang in two movies
Mirror Mirror yeah and rules don't apply
I'd love to do something where I get
this a more not happen does Lily Collins
have siblings I do I have four half
siblings Nicholas and Matthew were my
younger Joey and Simon are my older did
Lily Collins go to college yes I did I
went to USC sound to show Lily Collins
graduate oh not yet
I did like a six-month gap year I was
already working for Nickelodeon at the
time and it was during Obama's
campaigning inauguration so I was
reporting for him out in the field for
Nickelodeon and he was laughing
try ball muffin I wasn't reporting for
Nickelodeon about Obama's inauguration
and all that kind of stuff but I family
I'm so registered they just took me off
for like immediate registry they're
calling your name in roll call away at
the beginning of every day still not
here does Lily Collins have a child no I
do not have a child that was a Instagram
picture I did for April Fool's from love
Rosie but my little brother called me
the day I posted it and freaked out and
just said are you pregnant and I said
you think I wouldn't tell you like in
person and he goes oh god that sucks so
annoying I hate you and he hung up it's
good a little brothers huh minstrel a
sneaky one
so like is this our ed skrein and
nicholas hoult related we're not related
no but I can see why people make that
mistake cuz we look kind of similar
heads like a more masculine
better-looking version of me we have
done a movie together though I maybe
could kill your friends ah you happy can
I see one does nicholas hoult have a
brother yes I have an older brother
called James who's 12 years older than
me does nicholas hoult see yes very well
the kind of thing I kind of beg to
differ this sometimes when we've got
some Beyonce going on and you you pitch
in there pitching but normally the right
pitch right you also do very good lip
sync so I do lip sync is more my special
yeah yeah what does nicholas hoult look
like oh now it's right here ladies
doesn't it
he woke up like this alright last one
nicholas hoult zodiac sign Oh what is
nicholas hoult zodiac signs I'm a
Sagittarius what does that mean I'm not
really sure but no one's no one reacts
badly to it when I say said to
terrorists you know most the time people
go oh that's good so I feel like it's
also I'm so sorry yeah like I feel like
some star signs people react negatively
to mm-hmm but not Sagittarius as far as
I know it's a good thing conclusion
thank you so much for learning some more
facts about us and rediscovering ones
you already knew this has been fun
[Music]